hi guys right I'm Jerry let's do this
have fun trying to have fun by talking
over me yeah I just want to launch right
into our troubles America I didn't think
about it you don't sit down
heathen speaking of segregation x-men is
having TV spin-offs coming to TV shows a
show on FX called Legion and then Fox
they ordered an x-men TV series but
sounds really interesting it's about
these parents who have these human
parents who have kids that end up being
mutants and they end up going on the run
because the government or whatever is
after them when it's causes them to meet
up with other mutants to form up like a
partnership a bond becoming its own kind
of x-men I guess in some weird way
anyway I think it's cool what the x-men
franchise is doing they already have so
many multiple timelines in their movie
Cinematic Universe that I think why not
[ __ ] it up even more
but the TV shows yeah well I don't know
at least me as a viewer I'm pretty
relaxed to the point where if you want
to make each thing its own little world
yes yeah the légion show it to me
looking at the trailers for it
I don't know Allegiant is really about
but I kind of like that I don't want to
look up more about it well I like Noah
holiday a lot like I think he writes
some some cool kind of out-there stuff
so I I like Fargo a lot I totally agree
with that
and I think that the légion show looks
like an awesome FX show like it looks
kind of spooky it looks weird yeah it
looks like a gripping piece of material
like I feel like this could be a really
great stretch and I hear it's really
doing its own thing it's not really
worried about connecting to the movies I
hear us might not be connected to movies
at all actually which I'd be okay with I
think that's a great way to approach it
approach the mutant universe in a
different way I mean it's this Fox show
I'm a little bit concerned about
honestly I'm always concerned about our
TV now oh yeah I mean barring certain
things but when it especially jumping
out of like big scale action movies into
werk TV like I'm always a little whoa
from what it sounds like with the Fox
show about the family on the run it
sounds like they're you they want to
make that a little bit more part of the
mutant x-men world of the movies okay I
could say that better I want to make it
part of the x-men movies a little bit
more you know but like they've taught
the producer was talking about like you
know wolverine could exist in this
universe no just somewhere else or
something up is this the one that the
fox shows is the one but Burn Notice guy
right yeah okay I like Burn Notice I
know what Burn Notice is I don't know
like that's a reference to Donald
Trump's family television person you're
right like I think of like agents of
shield which didn't seem like it was
really getting like a great reputation
until they finally included like Ghost
Rider into their shell oh is that
working out like I don't really ever
hear about it
well it is working out and people seem
to be liking it more what the x-men TV
series I'm like if you're gonna do your
own TV series and even if it is still
connected to the the movies a little bit
like look at it like this alright great
example great example Joss Whedon he did
agents of shield pilot which is fine at
all but it just felt like a lower scale
movie of what the movies offer you and I
like Bryan Singer doing an x-men show
for the pilot it's like I'd rather just
have you guys making your own thing like
how Netflix shows for Marvel our slow
connected see the MCU but they still
feel like their own thing you know they
don't feel like they're trying to be
like the movies necessarily I feel like
Bryan Singer will probably just make it
feel like his movies that he's
established I get weary because you're
jumping from like all the keys to the
kingdom with the movies like you're used
to a certain level of action and effects
and then set pieces your yeah design and
all that and you know I'm sure Fox will
put a good amount of money into this but
still it's weird going backwards into a
into a smaller scale yeah well I feel
like any of the excellent movies don't
have to be like if you put like the
x-men movies on TV like ran it on Fox
for a night you only like bleep out a
few curse words here actually yeah with
the first good yeah yeah yeah and I
think it had the taste of Apocalypse and
well yeah I mean there's that say and
I'd probably be more excited Branson was
directing it if apocalypse was great but
he's still done like some pretty great
x-men films outside of that one that
yeah people don't think is that good
he's only had the one nun yeah he
established the [ __ ] x-men movies so
I could see it being cool it's just I
don't know I was like it's Bryan Singer
really have the passion to bring
something new and different or is this
more like a marketing maneuver he's
doing you know yeah directly to direct
the pilot establishes look and tone and
stuff it could be cool I've been
thinking between the two shows are more
excited for Legion off the oh yeah scene
the way it looks is much more I mean I
think this can work in either format
like especially thinking about it more
like x-men with the different kinds of
mutant capabilities and everything like
I think there's stuff you can do but if
you're gonna have to it at the same time
maybe there'll be conceptually just so
damn that they'll both work yeah I feel
like at least from what I've heard and
especially from what I've seen of Legion
like it it seems like that's the one I
would be much more interested by I feel
like there will be people confused by
these two ships ya know people like a
surprising amount of people were pretty
confused by you know what is this rogue
one movie I don't get it you know I hey
yeah there's a lot of people who were
like wait is this this is a sequel or
what is this going like people with the
star people just didn't know what was
going on with it and I feel like with
the x-men movies and then you have a
show that's kind of connected to the
movies then you have one show that has
no connection to the movies I feel like
people will get kind of confused by it
yeah well and I'm also because they they
said you know they're gonna give no
Holly like a good amount of room with
the FX show to kind of get out there and
make it his own which sounds more
intriguing we just feel like if the fox
show was doing that I'd be more
intrigued - yeah yeah yeah and that's
part of the thing for me like I saw the
poster for that somewhere and I saw the
you know the circle with the X in it and
the first thing that crossed my mind was
next
why is it called Legion you know I think
people could get it with Legion when I
watched that trailer it didn't seem like
it was trying to be too x-men Oh like it
seems I'm not probably gonna be really
it so there was nothing in there other
than the word mutants that really made
me go this is x-men yeah like if nobody
told me it was directly linked to x-men
I probably would just that like oh it's
just kind of like x-men yeah exactly
this is a more philosophical abstract
expec well what do you guys think of the
shows are you excited for it do you
still like Bryan Singer after x-men
apocalypse or have you lost all faith in
him to do another comic book movie just
like you did with Sam Raimi with
spider-man 3 even though he made
spider-man 1 and 2 which were both
amazing films put your comments below
subscribe to the reel rejects John
reasons to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of so
many things just look in the [ __ ]
description box Donald Trump calm